let's bring you some breaking news
coming in from Japan where tsunami waves
have been hitting its western coast
after a series of powerful earthquakes a
magnitude 7.6 Quake struck the Ishikawa
prefecture triggering tsunami alerts
along the Noto Peninsula when the prime
minister's office has issued evacuation
orders for several areas the government
is warning residents to prepare for
possible further earthquakes Japan's
Chief cabinet secretary has given a
press conference to reassure the
public following an earthquake that took
place today in Ishikawa at approximately
4:06 p.m. powerful Tremors measuring up
to seven on the shindo scale struck the
Noto peninsula in Ishikawa prefecture
beginning with the nearby shica nuclear
power plant there are currently no
reported irregularities with nuclear
power plants I humbly ask that all
citizens be cautious of the risk of
further earthquakes and request that
everyone living in the area where
powerful tremor took place pay close
attention to the local authorities
evacuation
orders evacuations are being carried out
on the Eastern Russian island of sahalin
the emergency Ministry has issued
tsunami alerts for parts of the
territory and officials in South Korea
say they're expecting waves triggered by
the Quakes to reach the East Coast at
any moment residents have been told to
move to Higher
Ground
well let's get the latest now from Chris
Gilbert who joins us live from Tokyo so
first of all let's start with the latest
warning how bad is the tsunami situation
looking
now well we've just uh received uh
reports that tsunamis have uh reached
the northern coastlines along that
western coast of Japan and these are
measuring somewhere between 50 cm to a
meter um just an hour or so ago there
was a tsunami of about 1.6 M that hit uh
near the epicenter on that Noto
Peninsula you mentioned earlier uh but
look we're heading into high tide in the
area in about half an hour from now and
uh the next 90 minutes are really going
to be uh a danger period the government
says for potential uh further tsunamis
now these are a far cry from what we saw
12 years ago uh you know after the great
uh earthquake then those tsunamis are
about 13 to 30 m but it only takes um
about half a meter to to knock someone
over in these tsunamis so uh this the
danger is still very real and the
government is asking everyone to stay
vigilant now there have uh been some
damage reports coming in how does it
look yeah these reports are coming in uh
the these are sparely populated areas
they're a little more full at the moment
uh people return to the countryside to
their hometowns for the New Year's
period and it does seem as though some
of the older typically older Japanese
style housing and other buildings from
these early videos and early reports do
seem to have uh collapsed especially in
the Noto Peninsula uh region uh there
are no confirmed uh fatalities of yet
there are some confirmed casualties in
fact there are reports coming that the
hospitals in the area are becoming
overwhelmed with people coming in uh
with uh injuries of of various uh you
know seriousness uh of course these
places don't have any power at the
moment about 3 3,000 households are
without power the hospitals are somewhat
without power and running on backup
generators and on top of that a large
fire has erupted in the city of wajima
on that Peninsula Noto Peninsula that's
a city of about 28,000 people and uh
that that fire does seem to be
significant so as the hours progress
we're going to learn a lot more about
the extent of the damage and Fallout
from this
earthquake all right we'll leave it
there thanks so much